it hurts it's unbearable sometimes there
have been many many times I've thought
I'm just quitting there have been so
many occasions when I've walked onto the
ward and it has been unsafe because of
the levels of Staffing you feel devalued
you feel a little bit worthless you feel
like you're not appreciated for what you
do
[Music]
Adele is a junior doctor in the UK's
National Health Service who walked out
of her Hospital in a four-day strike in
April which led to more than 195
000 missed appointments
the first half of 2023 the number of
canceled appointments amounted to almost
half a million as the medical sector
took part in the UK's Union actions over
the past year the UK has recorded the
largest number of strikes since the
1980s with sectors from Healthcare to
Postal Service workers and teachers all
taking industrial action it is not a
coincidence that they come at a time
when the cost of living crisis is
cutting into the pockets of the nation
with the cost of basic necessities
rocketing to new levels
strike by Junior doctors caused the
cancellation of almost 200 000
operations
the only thing we can really do is
strike and the only cause we can really
legitimately strike about is our pay but
it's sort of an indicator for loads of
other stuff Junior doctors are asking
for a 35 pay increase
this round of pay negotiations reflects
both the acute squeeze created by high
inflation now and more than a decade of
pay restraint that has seen public
sector workers fall way behind their
private sector counterparts so Junior
doctors their pay is increased by about
16 in cash terms in 2008 but in that
same period inflation and other factors
you know they're actually 25 percent
worse off and then to say enough is
enough I've been a junior doctor for
four years now I'm doing a 10 month long
contract in plastic surgery just to get
the experience I need in order to try
and make a successful application for my
actual training post my current job has
a higher base salary and so it's about
40 000 pounds but I never do night
shifts the extra hours the the night
shifts they really do make up the bulk
of our salaries so when you factor all
that together I've actually taken a
pretty decent pay cut
I will usually be scheduled to work with
one of the consultants in the operating
theaters within plastic surgery there's
loads of different things you could be
doing there's hand surgeries you can do
breast surgery so it's a lot of cancer
surgery plastic surgery includes Burns
so you might be doing skin grafting
plastic surgeons can do cleft lip and
palate surgery they can do head and neck
surgery which is largely taking tumors
at the moment I'm on call I started my
on-call shifts on Saturday and I will go
straight through until this Friday and
during those shifts we then have to do
trauma clinics so there's an awful lot
of strain within the NHS and the more
people are struggling
the more people are burning out since
I've started work it's not been uncommon
to hear someone say that one of their
colleagues has committed suicide
according to the British Medical
Association around 7 in 10 Junior
doctors surveyed say they always or
frequently work in understaffed rotors
which may be placing patient and staff
safety at risk around half of Junior
doctors described their desire to work
in the NHS in the next year as low or
very low
when you first move into a new house all
sorts of things spring up that you
weren't expecting to pay for when I
started my new job there was a mistake
made with my pay and it's taken five
months to get that resolved I've been
consistently worrying about money
consistently in my overdraft if any
unexpected thing happens you always feel
just a Heartbeat Away from absolute
disaster to be honest so when it comes
to painting NHS the government says that
it's set by these independent peer
review bodies which they say they can't
really interfere with these pair of new
bodies they will gather evidence over
the course of a year to give their
recommendation for maybe a two three
five percent pay rise and although you
know these strikes are kind of direct at
the government the government is trying
to you know take their hands out of it
and say it's not really our our deal at
the same time we're getting a bit of an
impact right now Geo doctors are asking
for what's called full pay restoration
which would be a 35 periods right now
the government's saying that it's
completely unaffordable and unacceptable
and they have to lower that
you know there are some things that you
see at work or that you do at work that
if you were to say them to a person who
doesn't work in healthcare they just
wouldn't understand why you're upset
okay did you work last night yeah yeah
so this is night three or four for me so
um it's slightly delirious but it's okay
we're gonna get through it so I think
pay is a a difficult issue on bank
holidays the person in the hospital paid
the least is the the F1 so the junior
Doctor Who's been a doctor for a year so
you get paid more in the hospital to
clean toilets on a bank holiday it
hasn't been safe for for many years and
I I don't think that'll come as a shock
to to anyone
there is nowhere else that a junior
doctor can work we can't even work in
private hospitals because the reason
people go private is to ensure that they
get seen by a consultant so really our
only options are ditch the NHS entirely
a lot of people have moved to to places
like Australia and New Zealand where
you're valued more highly now two out of
five doctors said in a recent poll that
they are looking into media ages or
wouldn't accept another job if that was
proposed and 80 are actually saying that
they're constantly thinking about ways
out as well the ability to continue
striking is what's proving difficult
because you know we're striking because
we are not being paid enough and we
therefore don't don't really have the
ability to take that much unpaid leave
from our work
so I think the longer the strikes go on
the more difficult it's going to be but
I think the majority of people have
reached the point where they are going
to do anything they have to in order to
be able to continue striking and making
that point the fact that people are
still willing to fight tells me that
people have hope that things will get
better
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign